joe biden continues to push build back
better while democratic hopes go sour in
virginia the white house tells americans
they can also live the
government-dependent life of linda and
the government prepares to pay illegal
immigrant families separated at the
border huge dollars i'm ben shapiro this
is the bench bureau show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben here is your reminder you are
spending way too much money on your cell
phone bill right now you think you need
one of the big providers like verizon
att t-mobile because they have all the
best cell towers but here's the thing
what if you could have access to all of
those cell towers without any of the
extra costs associated with their
massive marketing campaigns or the
stores that you never visit this is what
pure talk does for you pure talk isn't
going to charge you for any of that
stuff instead they give you killer 5g
coverage on the same 5g network as one
of the big guys for about half the cost
the average family is saving over 800 a
year so what exactly is your excuse i
made the switch you can keep your number
keep your phone or get huge discounts on
the latest iphones and androids get a
limited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and if you
still want unlimited data you can still
get it and save a fortune go to
puretalk.com shop for the plan that is
right for you
they have a 30-day risk-free guarantee
so you literally have nothing to lose go
to puretalk.com enter promo code shapiro
you will save 50 off your very first
month of coverage that's puretalk.com
promo code shapiro puretalk is simply
smarter wireless there's no reason for
you to be spending a fortune above and
beyond what you have to spend for your
cell phone provider coverage this is why
pure talk is just way better than
verizon at t or t-mobile go check out
puretalk today at puretalk.com promo
code shapiro to say 50 off your very
first month of coverage okay so before
we get to the latest in the build back
better drama and whether joe biden is
going to be able to cram through this
1.75 trillion dollar boondoggle which
actually is not 1.75 trillion it's
actually closer to 3 trillion as we will
discuss it is important to mention that
everything right now in terms of the
democratic hopes relies on glenn
youngken not winning in virginia so this
virginia gubernatorial race has now
become one of the great shockers in
modern american political history the
polling shows glen youngkin up there two
separate polls out yesterday showing
glenn young can up substantially on
terry mcauliffe remember this is a state
that joe biden won just a few months
back by 10 points
this the state has now shifted
dramatically against the party of the
president of the united states according
to a brand new poll provided to the
washington examiner youngkin is now at
47 and mcauliffe is at 43.
okay and that's not the only poll that
is like this there's another poll that
is out from fox news fox news
historically has been a very
pro-mcauliffe poll
the new poll shows young can up eight
points on akala 53 to 45.
he leads among young king leads among
registered voters by one point and
likely voters by eight
young kittens had plus 14 with parents
plus 11 on the economy plus eight on
education plus 12 on crime and even plus
one on covid
okay we are only a few days out from the
election
now this is not the first time that
something like this has happened
actually
bob mcdonnell when he won election in
virginia that had been right after a
democratic sweep and then he won
election in virginia by like a wide
margin he shifted from a plus six
democratic states like a plus 17 state
for bob mcdonnell so virginia does have
a habit of backlashing against
radicalism and that's what you are
seeing right here and democrats have to
be running a little bit scared because
mcauliffe has run on the biden agenda
and by yelling trump a lot and it's not
working
the biden agenda is really unpopular
bringing in joe biden to try and save
the day had apparently no impact
americans are still concerned with the
radicalism of critical race theory they
are still concerned with whether they
get to control their kids education
they're still concerned with inflation
they're concerned with all the issues
democrats would prefer they not care
about and the democratic solution for
all these problems is to continue to
throw money at it well if glenn youngkin
upsets terry mcauliffe who remember is a
revered figure inside the democratic
party he's a former governor of virginia
he's the former head of dnc he's a
hillary clinton acolyte if terry
mcauliffe goes down to flaming defeat in
virginia they're going to be a lot of
congress people blue dog democrats if
they still exist some of the senators
are going to say um i don't really want
to reap the whirlwind in order to push
through a bill that is just loaded with
pork for joe biden's friends it does not
seem like a good deal okay so this is
why joe biden is trying to push this
through he needs to ram this through so
yesterday joe biden tried to ram this
thing through the infrastructure bill at
the very least so his basic idea was
divide up the infrastructure bill and
build back better why well if we can get
the infrastructure bill passed then
there will be no leverage for the
progressive caucus on the billback
better plan because they'll either have
to vote it up or vote it down but
they'll be voting it up or down
in the absence of any piece of leverage
if they vote against the bill then the
bill just goes down to defeat they don't
get any win out of it
it just looks like spite if however they
hold up the infrastructure plan in order
to get people to put more pork into the
buildback better plan then they have a
little bit of leverage
so
joe biden was really pushing yesterday
for an infrastructure plan vote he
wanted that vote yesterday he put out a
framework for bill back better he hoped
that this would get the congressional
progressive caucus on board to vote for
the infrastructure plan and then he
could separate off bill back better and
then he wouldn't have to worry about the
progressives he could just go ahead and
push forward his moderate plan get
enough votes on the democratic side of
the aisle to do it and the progressives
would probably join in because it's
better for them to build to vote up or
down on buildback better and vote in
favor than not to vote for it at all
right the leverage game is over if
there's a vote on the infrastructure
plan so late last night joe biden was
pushing very hard for there to be a vote
nancy pelosi was pushing hard for there
to be a vote this is the second straight
week nancy pelosi has said they wanted
to vote on infrastructure and this is
the second straight week that it simply
didn't happen so if this extends if this
discussion extends all the way past the
election next week which is happening on
november 2nd if that election ends up
going in glen youngkin's favor i think
it's gonna be very difficult for
democrats to pass anything that looks
remotely like even what they're
discussing right now because none of the
details have been worked out maybe they
get an infrastructure plan but it's hard
to imagine that mansion who's in the
state next door to lenyonkin
and cinema who's going to be running a
competitive race next time she didn't
win by very much last time
that both of them are going to be
deeply interested in voting for bill
back better so remember that cinema and
mansion are actually just shielding a
couple of other democrats in the senate
who are really in tight races right now
so maggie hassan in new hampshire for
example is not guaranteed to re-elect in
her race
sununu might run in that race if he runs
she's in real trouble so if she votes
for bill back better and votes for tax
increases in a state that is very low
tax state new hampshire it doesn't like
taxes very much she could easily lose
that seat that's another senator who is
going to be on the firing line if young
can wins in virginia mark kelly is in
arizona
he ran a very competitive race last time
but there's no reason why he wouldn't be
highly vulnerable if this bill passes
with his vote and it passes on a
straight party online vote 50 50.
so what happens in virginia matters an
awful lot which is why joe biden is
trying to force this thing through fast
what's amazing is that he's he's trying
to force this thing through in the face
of overwhelming evidence that the
american people are not interested his
approval ratings are down in the low 40s
and the harder he pushes his plan the
lower his approval ratings go
plus the u.s economy in q3 just died it
just laid down and died
it laid an egg according to the
washington post the us economy grew at a
disappointing 2.0 percent annual rate in
the third quarter
as the delta variant peaked but
promising signs suggest 2021 is on track
to notch the fastest full year growth in
almost four decades i love how the
washington post has to try and salvage
joe biden from himself so right now you
should not be having quarterly growth of
two percent you should have you should
be having quarterly annualized growth of
seven or eight percent it is what was
forecast all year long
yes there's gonna be a fast growth year
overall because we had the worst year in
terms of gdp growth in modern american
history last year because of the
artificial shutdown of the entire
economy thanks to kovit
but joe biden's policies have now
crimped an economy that should have been
racing ahead at full speed because he's
pushed inflationary policy because he
has pushed bad tax policy because he has
made people unlikely to invest and even
if you are investing you can't even get
workers out there he's paying people to
stay home bill back better does that too
and joe biden's answer as always is more
cowbell so they've put they've got a
real pickle on their hands they're kind
of stuck here if they push bill back
better and it passes
they might lose the senate and if they
don't pass bill back better then it
looks like joe biden is incompetent and
he can't get his party together
now both of those things can be true
but if either one of them is true he's
got a real problem come 2022.
the notion that this 1.75 trillion
dollar budget plan is suddenly going to
jog the economy is totally crazy it's
not going to jog the economy
it's simply going to be pushing more
money into an economy that's already
inflating and joe biden is not making a
convincing case for his own agenda so
yesterday he was making the case for
bill back better again he's on the stump
and as i say joe biden on the stump is
basically just two tree stumps on top of
each other because joe biden is himself
a stump so it's a stump atop another
stump so joe biden from the white house
yesterday was trying to push forward his
build back better plan he put forward in
a a framework okay not the actual plan
so when people say they'll vote for it
or vote against it it doesn't mean
anything until we actually have all of
the details but he put together a
framework and he basically said i'm
skipping town tomorrow right because
today he's headed over to europe to
jabber with the europeans about global
warming or some such
and hang out with the pope in a
non-televised event and and joe biden
he says i'm gonna dump this framework
out there and then i'm gonna pretend
like we've achieved some sort of grand
progress here here he was yesterday
trying to push bill back better and of
course he is not an inspiring figure
folks
this framework includes historic
investments in our nation and on our
people
any single element of this framework
would fundamentally view would be viewed
as a fundamental change in america taken
together
they're truly consequential
okay
inspiring stuff the words of a of a
charismatic leader there from joe biden
i'm sure he's going to start convincing
people maybe if he yells at us maybe
just randomly yells in the middle of
sentences that'll do it
we used to lead the world in educational
achievement
now the organization for economic
cooperation and development ranks
america 35th
out of the 37 major countries when it
comes to investing in early childhood
education and care
we know how our children start
impact significantly and how they'll
finish
he's very angry at you i don't know why
he's angry at you you didn't do it also
head start as we will discuss in a
little bit which is kind of a big part
of this program and basically trying to
universalize head start it starts a
giant fail it's a giant waste of money
okay and then you might think okay well
you have some questions for this guy
because after all he's willing to stand
there and take blow after blow on behalf
of his plans uh nope he is uh he's going
to run away he's brave to robin running
away here we go as always
thank you
catch you later
bye-bye and there's joe stumbling out of
the room on his way to europe what an
inspiring figure amazing stuff okay so
again joe biden's plan as of yesterday
was let's get the infrastructure vote
done so he throws out the framework
hoping that the congressional
progressives will endorse the framework
and feel so comfortable that they then
vote on the infrastructure plan which
takes away all their leverage on the
framework well wrong he was according to
politico the house voted thursday night
to temporarily reauthorize
transportation funding abruptly
reversing coors after democratic leaders
earlier vowed to pass a bipartisan
senate approved infrastructure bill the
move came after progressives refused to
relent in their opposition to the 550
billion infrastructure bill amid a
standoff over democrats separate party
line 1.75 trillion social spending
measure it followed a visit to capitol
hill by president biden who personally
asked house democrats for their support
on both of them
nope
nope speaker nancy pelosi and her
leadership team were ultimately unable
to win over dozens of dug-in liberals in
time for a thursday evening vote instead
they're now breaking for the weekend
house liberals said they want to review
the legislative text of the 1.75
trillion social spending legislation the
white house outlined on thursdays like
sixteen hundred pages of garbage and get
a commitment of support from centrist
senators joe manchin and kirsten cinema
something the two have not given
outright at this point and again cinema
and mansion when i say that they are
really on razor's edge here if young can
wins in virginia they have got to be
looking at their political futures and
saying if i vote for this thing
what exactly do i get
despite an aggressive whipping campaign
from democratic leaders as many as 30
liberal democrats threatened to block
the roughly 550 billion senate passed
infrastructure bill according to
multiple people familiar with the vote
tallying operation
as house democrats headed home for the
weekend in defeat many were infuriated
and left wondering how they had stumbled
yet again pointing fingers within their
own party
congressional progressive caucus chair
representative pramila jayapal she said
i tried to tell anybody who had listened
that we didn't have the votes
she then added we want assurances that
bill back better is going to pass in the
senate before we commit to actually
passing the infrastructure vote here's
representative pramila jayapal who on
the left is running things for the
democratic party
we need to see both votes on the on the
bill back better act and the
infrastructure bill moving forward
together
um we also want to see
uh the commitment from the two senators
and and frankly all 50 senators that
they are also supportive of this
framework and that it will be passed
with no undermining in the senate
okay so again the progressives are not
going to give up their leverage they dug
their teeth in
and biden and pelosi really can't do
much about that at all other than trying
to get the progressives on board for
actual build back better
again the more time that passes the
worse this gets for the democrats
remember we are now at the end of
october by next week we'll be into
november at the beginning of december
the democrats face the debt ceiling
again so if they don't actually have a
deal by the time they hit december
republicans are not extending that debt
ceiling again it's going to have to be
done solely with
the the reconciliation
process via solely democratic votes
democrats
are in trouble here and even if they
pass this they are in trouble get some
more on this in just one second first if
you're like me you probably want to make
sure that you have a diversified
portfolio but here is the thing bond
yields right now are flatter than the
state of florida you can only buy so
much gold and savings account are not
even keeping up with inflation
if you don't act inflation could turn
your hard-earned cash into trash so what
exactly should you do economic experts
are suggesting you invest in alternative
assets one that's been getting a lot of
attention lately is blue chip art it's
recently grown in volume 2700 beat the s
p 500 between 1995 and 2020 and it has
outperformed every other asset during
financial downturns in fact contemporary
art returned 23.2
during periods with more than 30
inflation
now a lot of people who are very wealthy
have always hedged their portfolio with
art it's actually a great way of hedging
your portfolio but you're kind of a
normal person you don't have millions of
dollars lying around to buy a banksy
well now here is the thing there's a
company it's called masterworks.io
they've come up with a great idea
they're selling shares of million dollar
paintings so now you can invest in the
same art billionaires use to safeguard
their wealth with masterworks there's a
number of great reasons to do so they're
the world's only one billion dollar
alternative investment platform that
securitized over 80 paintings with the
sec everyday investors have already
invested over 250 million dollars and
many of them are ben shapiro show
listeners so you will be joining your
friends i've partnered with masterworks
to get you vip access despite the fact i
have a waitlist that gives you priority
access to their latest painting to find
out what it is head on over to
masterworks dot io ben the offering
sellout fast you don't want to wait
that's masterworks dot io slash ben
before deciding to invest carefully
review the important disclosures at
masterworks dot io
disclaimer alrighty so
again the progressives are holding up
the infrastructure bill because they
want more from the build back better
plan here's bernie sanders making that
statement yesterday it is amazing how
the bernie sanders wing of the
democratic party now has real influence
from day one both of these bills are
linked
i support the infrastructure bill
uh but i want to see a strong build back
better bill as well and they're linked
together so what you don't want to see
is the infrastructure bill passed and
then not have uh the kind of buildback
better bill that we need and that's why
you need 50 members uh on board before
uh there should be a vote in my view uh
in the house
now politico is trying to spend this as
a win for biden somehow but they're
trying to spend his win for biden is the
fact that giapollo and the cpc put out a
statement on the status of the build
back better negotiations in which they
said that they overwhelmingly voted to
endorse in principle the entire build
back better act framework announced by
biden today they say we appreciate the
president's leadership and his
commitment to getting this process over
the finish line he reaffirmed as our
caucus has month after month that both
the infrastructure bill and the popular
build back better act must move together
because they are part of the same agenda
today we are reiterating our
enthusiastic commitment to delivering
that entire agenda to people across
america the reality is that while talks
around the infrastructure bill lasted
months in the senate there's only been
serious discussion around the specifics
of the larger build back better act in
recent weeks thanks to the progressive
caucus holding the line and putting both
parts of the agenda back on the table
now congress needs to finish the job and
bring both bills to a vote together this
can't be accomplished without
legislative texts that can be fully
assessed and agreed upon by all the
parties
so
politico was trying to play this as a
win for biden because the cpc said that
they agree with the framework but
agreeing with a framework don't mean
squad if they really agreed with the
framework they would have voted on the
infrastructure plan yesterday which they
didn't and nancy pelosi is super pissed
about it according to politico earlier
in the day until they called the vote
off thursday evening pelosi and other
top democrats had been firm in their
calls to vote projecting confidence
pelosi teed up a house rules committee
meeting on a bill text that will make up
the base of the social spending bill
cabinet members outside advocates also
pushed liberals to back the
infrastructure bill before biden landed
in rome
pelosi said quote let's do it in timely
fashion let's not just keep having
postponements and leaving doubt as to
when this would happen
well um
nope
so the progressives are like guess what
nancy we don't work for you she cannot
control her caucus here's corey bush the
adjunct member of the squad from
missouri saying i'm not going to vote
for bill back better
there are home care workers that came to
me in my district that cried because
they were talking about nobody fights
for us congresswoman you are our
congresswoman will you fight for us i'll
remember those faces right now i will
not turn my back on those home care
workers i won't turn my back on teachers
and principals i won't turn my back on
on um uh anyone else in our community we
can't just look at one sec of our
community we have to look at the whole
of it and they deserve this so corey
bush i stand with my people all of them
okay so meanwhile
representative ilhan omar she's doing
the same thing she says both bills or
none on infrastructure
we need to keep the promise
that was made we've been very clear
we need to see the two bills
simultaneously move together
if there is urgency in getting this done
the senators need to understand that
urgency as well
and move
as urgent as they want us to move so
that we can get the two legislation
okay so according to punchbowl which is
another dc insidery publication quote
there's no denying thursday's episode
was an embarrassing setback for
democrats biden included biden was
supposed to help pelosi bridge and ugly
split between moderates and progressives
that didn't happen in fact it may be
even worse strangely when biden met with
house democrats on thursday he didn't
ask them to vote for the bipartisan
infrastructure bill which pelosi was
trying to get to the floor instead the
president urged rank and file lawmakers
to
to back both the infrastructure bill and
the framework for the build back better
act which the white house unveiled early
that morning pelosi had to jump up and
say they should vote for the
infrastructure bill first
progressive notice biden's omission they
later argued that biden had given them
the green light to say no on
infrastructure so joe biden came in like
the senile daughtering fool that he is
and he completely undercut nancy pelosi
pelosi is like we want to give you the
infrastructure win and then they won't
have any leverage on billback better and
we can do exactly what you want mr
president and biden came in he's like
well yeah you should vote for well we
made a promise we're gonna vote for both
of them together
and the progressives like see
he's on our side and pelosi is like i
don't even know what to do anymore i
don't i don't know
according to punchbowl this wasn't just
an oversight by biden the white house
then adopted a deliberate hands-off
approach to yesterday's scheduled vote
according to democratic lawmakers
and then apparently there was a call
between the white house legislative
director of legislative affairs luisa
terrell national economic council
director brian deese seeing several
senior white house officials and key
democratic lawmakers apparently terrell
was repeatedly asked to spell out their
position on infrastructure
representative suzanne delbine from
washington chair of the new democrat
coalition asked straight out whether
biden wanted house democrats to vote for
the infrastructure bill the white house
officials then said they support both
bills which again undercut pelosi
we would have had a victory today if
only he had asked for it one democratic
aide instead of biden
so complete debacle politico tried to
play it as a win punchbowl is actually
being a lot more honest but it just once
again demonstrates that this
administration does not know what the
hell it is doing and they have no
leverage over the progressive members of
their coalition
i think honestly i think that when it
comes right down to it i'm not sure that
biden even wants to pass the damn thing
i think biden says he wants to pass the
thing and then he wants to run in 2024
on republican obstructionism the problem
is he's got a democratic caucus it makes
it so difficult for him in some ways the
worst thing that has happened to biden
is the fact that republicans blew both
of those georgia senate races because
now there's been an actual ask made of
democrats if mitch mcconnell were
running the senate we all know this
would be doa but because it's mansion in
cinema it's put biden in a box of his
own making because he is not pursuing
anything remotely like a moderate policy
and they are making clear biden is that
so much of this is is performative
the way that he is marketing buildback
better is not as a moderate attempt to
shore up holes in the social safety net
he's he's pushing it as a transformative
plan that is going to radically redefine
how economics is done in the united
states
and so maybe his goal is that nothing
passes because then he can say that he
was trying to be transformative and
everybody else failed him
because just like barack obama
the president can never fail you can
only fail the president we'll get some
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about a simple fact right now
is a great time to refine your house and
you better do it fast because the fed is
going to begin tapering the mortgage
rates are going to go up next year now
is a really really good time to refi
your mortgage you might be thinking why
your mortgage is fine well what you
should be asking is how your mortgage
could work for you and that answer can
be found at american financing america's
home for home loans
they don't pressure you instead their
salary based mortgage consultants get to
know you so they can lead you to greater
overall savings it could be a shorter
loan term or consolidating debt because
there's more to refinance than just a
lower rate it's the reason why they save
customers up to a thousand bucks a month
so why not see what they can do for you
make the 10 minute call right now before
those rates are gone 866 721 3300 that's
eight six six seven two one thirty three
hundred or visit americanfinancing.net
nmls one eight two three three four
nmlsconsumeraccess.org
again your biggest monthly bill is
undoubtedly your mortgage if you can
lower that why would you not even like
make the call
just give american financing a call
right now at 866 721 3300 that's 866 721
3300 or visit americanfinancing.net
that's americanfinancing.net
alrighty so
joe biden again he is pitching this
entire thing as a transformative policy
americans are not interested in your
stupid transformative nonsense at a
moment when the economy should be
booming but is not thanks to your policy
failures now it is amazing how the media
are reporting that last quarter's
economic downturn was largely due
to delta not to the policies of the body
administration and blue state governors
we know that's not true because here in
florida where we have a red state
governor and we are not paying attention
to anything that joe biden has to say
the economy is booming once again i
repeat it is the single most important
economic statistic because if the states
are laboratories of democracy then their
policies ought to show some differences
if you look at the unemployment rate by
states in the united states right now
i'm looking at the bureau of labor
statistics for september
okay here are the best states in terms
of employment here's the list again i'll
do it again okay utah okay nebraska's
number one red utah red idaho red new
hampshire purple south dakota red
vermont purple well vermont's kind of
blue oklahoma red alabama red georgia
red montana red north dakota red
minnesota blue missouri red virginia now
turning purple
kansas red wisconsin purple arkansas
red indiana red iowa red south carolina
north carolina red red kentucky red
tennessee red wyoming red okay are you
noticing a pattern here these are all
the best states in terms of unemployment
now let's go to the bottom of the list
okay here are the worst states in terms
of unemployment right now nevada blue
california blue new york blue new jersey
blue new mexico blue illinois blue
connecticut blue hawaii blue dc blue
okay you noticing a pattern at all here
okay so if this is supposedly just about
delta why this heavy striation
thanks to
obvious political consideration
especially because delta this wave hit
the red states okay so if the idea is
the delta is what hurt the economy you
would expect a massive jump in
unemployment in southern red states but
some of the states that i just read to
you are not southern i mean are not uh
are some of the states that most of the
states that have high unemployment rates
are not southern and had no delta spike
and a lot of the states that i read to
the very beginning are southern and had
serious delta spikes
right in that list of states that i was
reading to you
was the state of tennessee major delta
spike
was the state of georgia syria's delta
so what exactly is the deal guys it
looks more like this has less to do with
delta than it has to do with political
policy
the democrats have to keep claiming and
the media have to repeat it that the
real economic downturn is not democratic
policy when we all know that it is and
they have to keep claiming that so we
will pretend that joe biden's massive
spending plan isn't going to be just as
damaging as the rest of his garbage
agenda so what exactly is in his budget
framework
according to the wall street journal
editorial board
the blueprint the white house released
is more frame than work the jury rig
plan is an enormous expansion of
government with quarter-baked
entitlement programs that will retired
work and 1.58 trillion dollars in tax
increases that will distort and limit
investment the 1.75 trillion dollar cost
the democrats have assigned is a lie
they use phony accounting to finance a
few years of new spending with 10 years
of tax increases for example the plan
extends the 3600 child tax credit for
one year at a cost of 110 billion
dollars but democrats are going to
extend it next year
if it's extended for 10 years that would
be 1.1 trillion dollars not 110 billion
dollars so literally they are saying
that the cost of a program they are
extending is 110 billion dollars the
actual cost over 10 years if it were
extended as they hope to do is 1.1
trillion so it's a false sunset
the agreement drops the house's proposed
medicare vision and dental expansion but
preserves a new hearing benefit which
the white house claims will cost a mere
34 billion dollars and start in 2024.
the annual cost of the hearing benefit
once fully phased in is 16 billion
congress will make it permanent true
cost 160 billion dollars
and this sort of stuff is true
throughout the bill
the real cost is likely closer to four
trillion dollars than 1.75 trillion
dollars
meanwhile the plan is to ratchet up
taxes in a wide variety of ways
they're trying to claim 400 billion
dollars in revenues from 80 billion
dollars in quote irs investments a 66
budget increase for the irs including
hiring more auditors does this sound
like fun to you
you really want more auditors looking
down your neck
is that really what like breathing on
your neck that's what you want
more irs
who in the united states was like you
know what we need more of irs auditors
huge we need more people at the irs
americans hate the irs and for good
reason
by the way it's a lie that this is going
to claim 400 billion in revenue the cbo
says this is only going to yield 200
billion in revenue
and because we're spending 80 billion on
the irs to build them new toilets it's
actually only gonna net about 120
billion dollars to the federal
government
also
the 1.85 trillion dollars in tax
increases includes a 15 minimum tax on
book income of large corporations but we
all know what's going to happen here
democrats are then going to create carve
outs for all their friends
corporations are going to be taxed on
stock buybacks so corporations will just
shift the way they pay people from stock
buybacks to share dividends
despite its anti-corporate advertising
the bill is a giant boondoggle for it's
basically solyndra
they're they're dedicating 555 billion
dollars for climate spending
investing in renewables nuclear hydrogen
carbon capture electric vehicles
batteries and transmission lines that's
on top of the tens of billions in green
energy handouts in the senate
infrastructure bill
okay that's how much of that is going to
be efficient spending the answer is very
little
the truth is that the government invests
in a lot of projects you never see the
benefits of the vast majority of them
and very often it's corrupt we know this
because
when barack obama tried to do the exact
same thing remember those green jobs
that were supposed to materialize and it
turns out it was all just a lie
also we're going to see massive tax
increases a 5 surge tax on income over
10 million bucks 8 percent over 25
million
those sur taxes raise the top marginal
personal income tax rate to 45 or so and
in new york and california
where you have state tax on top of that
the people at the top of the tax
brackets are going to be paying 60 new
york and california how many
billionaires are you thinking to stick
around in new york and california for
that
see it doesn't make a difference to them
if the marginal tax increase between
like new york and florida is not all
that great but if you're talking about
the difference between paying say a 45
tax rate and a 60 tax rate
get ready red states for a lot of income
because everybody's going to be moving
on down to texas and florida which is
the reason the nancy pelosi and company
wanted to restore the salt deduction
right they wanted to make sure that you
paid your state income tax first so they
could essentially give a subsidy to the
blue states
so the bill is a full-scale disaster and
it's it's filled again with this notion
that there's a great urgency to do all
of this
and i'm sorry but there isn't a great
urgency to do all of this
particularly the 500 billion dollars on
climate change nonsense
i mean that that's the single biggest
part of the bill is 500 billion 555
billion dollars to fight climate change
largely through tax incentives for low
emission sources of energy
okay well here is the thing those tax
incentives for low emission sources of
energy are not going to marginally
they're really not going to any in any
real way lower the carbon emissions
okay people putting solar on their house
is not going to make
the the rate of global warming decrease
in any serious material way over the
course of the next 100 years
what you need is actual innovation and
innovation is generally derived from
making things marketable
and not from simply throwing money at
the problem
they're not even dedicating that 555
billion dollars to to the kind of
infrastructure change that would be
necessary to cope with rising climate
now you'll remember that last year well
this year actually there's this big
hurricane
it swept through the south memory is
very similar to hurricane katrina it
didn't do nearly as much damage why
because they'd short up the
infrastructure
in new orleans we should be spending
money on that kind of stuff
like why the northeast got completely
flooded one of the reasons it got
completely flooded is because the
infrastructure there is not so good
but the progressives are like we're not
going to build that infrastructure
instead we are going to need 555 billion
dollars to pay the shmuck down the
street to get a tesla
okay but by the way that is not a poor
people thing teslas are very expensive
subsidizing electric cars are not
something that impoverished people in
this country are deeply worried about
right now
so this is one thing that the the wild
left is very enthusiastic about and they
have to try and scare you into believing
that we need to spend this kind of money
so you have the irrepressible
irredeemable
aoc so fresh so faced faceness and
freshness abounding saying that entire
regions of the united states are going
to be unlivable unless she can put her
hand in your wallet take out all of your
money and then hand it to a bunch of
people who vote democrat
by 2028
crop yields are be are already projected
to begin to fail with famine beginning
to hit the world's most vulnerable
populations by 2038
current u.s drought fire and extreme
heat trends make will could potentially
make whole regions of the united states
unlivable if we continue the trends that
lobbyists are trying
to to
have us pursue
who actually believes this
really first of all there are already
regions of the united states where
people don't live okay they're broad
swaths of the west where people just
don't live
okay and people will move people will
adapt as they have literally throughout
human history remember there used to be
an actual land bridge between asia and
the united states and uh and north
america
it doesn't exist anymore there's there's
a c over it climate change has been a
perennial of human existence
people have adapted to it
i am i guess optimistic because now
she's extended her timeline for doomed
to 2038 you'll recall that a couple of
years ago she said we had 12 years or
the earth was going to completely eat us
it's just going to open up like that
like the book of of numbers and just
swallow us whole
meanwhile i have ayanna presley saying
this is a climate justice bill i
this is not what the word justice means
guys i mean like
the word justice has a meaning and when
you just add some other word in front of
it
to mean a thing that i like it doesn't
mean anything anymore here's ayanna
presley pushing this
one climate scientist said quote what we
do in the next 10 years will matter for
10 000 years unquote i believe that what
we do in the next 10 days on
infrastructure investments will be the
true predictor of our planet's future
the buildback better act is a climate
justice bill and a workers justice bill
we can and we must act with urgency
thank you and i yield back
climate and workers justice and
everything justice and uh it's so
tiresome it's so tiresome it all is
linked together with the progressive
agenda to call everything once you
premise you so corey bush yesterday
she started berating oil executives uh
by calling them white supremacists
because they drill for oil or something
i don't even understand what she's
talking about now
for years you all have continued to
promote fossil fuels despite knowing
that promoting them means promoting
environmental racism and violence in
black and brown communities you all are
still promoting and selling fossil fuels
that are killing millions of people this
is a striking example of white supremacy
your profit-driven choices threaten my
life the lives of my family my neighbors
and our communities every single day
um i'm sorry oil threatens black
communities every single day
truly you know it seems kind of like
white supremacy to me frankly a bunch of
upper crust white liberals in the main
who are telling a bunch of countries
largely people of color that they cannot
have economic development because we are
deeply concerned that over the course of
the next hundred years they might have
to move their beach houses in the united
states that seems a lot more like white
supremacy than people drilling for oil
so that people can live and not abject
poverty
uh honestly carbon-based fuel is one of
the great discoveries of mankind and
thank god we are now developing
alternative sources of energy people are
buying tesla it is good that people are
buying teslas i'm very much in favor of
it
i'm glad that we're doing fracking
because natural gas is much more
is much more environmentally friendly
than than oil and coal right like all
that's true
but the notion that oil executives are
complicit in white supreme again it is
all just ball everything up in one ball
and we need to redo how the world works
in one second we're going to get to the
democratic perspective on redoing how
the world works because this is really
what it comes down to they want every
single human in the united states to be
dependent on the government they think
that this is a fulfilling life
fulfillment lies in you being dependent
on the government playing husband and
father to you we'll get to more of this
in just one second first you know those
gas prices that i was talking about a
moment ago you know the gas prices are
truly spiking they're out of control if
you are in california in some place
you're paying like seven bucks a gallon
you need get upside my listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up just
download that free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code shapiro get a bonus 25 cents
per gallon on your first fill up that's
up to 50 cents cash back don't pay full
price of the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside just download the app
for free use promo code shapiro to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cash back on
your first tank some people who drive a
lot are making as much as two to three
hundred bucks a month in cash back
there's no cash the cash gets added
right back to your account you can cash
out anytime to your bank account paypal
or an e-gift card for amazon and other
brands just download the free get upside
app use promo code shapiro you get up to
50 cents per gallon cashback on your
first tank that is code shapiro go check
them out right now again get the free
get upside app right now and use promo
code shapiro you get up to 50 cents per
gallon cashback on your very first tank
of gas now is an excellent time for you
to be saving money on gas get upside go
check it out right now we'll get to more
in just one second first it is that
glorious time of the week when i give a
shout out to a daily war member today
it's summer lillenberg on instagram who
understands the importance of proper
parenting in the pick summer is happily
sitting with her two adorable children
while holding the world's greatest
beverage vessel the caption reads just
trying to raise the next generation
right with my hashtag leftist tears
tumblr now that's some excellent momming
right there keep up the good work and
never ever allow your children within
the purview of the loudoun county school
board thanks for the pick and for being
a daily wire member also
let me remind you that one of the things
that we here at daily wire are very big
on is fighting back against the leftist
culture okay and the leftist culture is
costing people their jobs which is why
we are very proud to bring on board
allison williams seasoned sports
reporter from espn you remember she
announced her resignation last week from
espn because essentially they forced her
out the door she didn't want to get
vaccinated because she already had
natural immunity and she was looking to
get pregnant and she had questions and
yes piano was like well there's the door
well now she works here which we are
super excited about because the fact is
that quality people are being forced out
and we are going to pick them up and we
are going to give you excellent content
frankly we're excited that the leftists
have decided to throw all their talented
people out the door because they refuse
to abide by leftist tot so if you want
to help us do this provide a place for
people to land and give you great
content you need to help us out at
dailywire.com subscribe use code do not
comply at checkout for 25 off we're
building a movement against the leftist
hollywood machine and joe biden's
unconstitutional mandate we do need your
help go to dailywire.com subscribe code
do not comply for 25 off and join the
fight also reminder you need to listen
to morning wire morning wire is great
not only has it been topping the apple
and spotify charts since its release
it's the only daily podcast that values
your time and the truth it's 15 minutes
or less all the news you need to know
subscribe start listening now to
morningwire on applespotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts leave a five star
review if you like what you hear you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so again the democrats are
trying to force through the notion that
this is everything that they are doing
is is required because if not the world
will burn and this is why they're
focusing in on climate change
everything's a crisis because whenever
you can declare a crisis this means that
you can take absolute control so over
the last year and a half we had an
actual crisis in the form of a global
pandemic that's killed millions of
people but nobody i mean but nobody
actually thinks that climate change over
the course of the next century is a
crisis it may be a problem it might be a
serious problem that we need to deal
with no one thinks it's a crisis that
requires us to dump out trillions of
dollars from a piggy bank that does not
exist into an economy that's already
overheated nobody thinks that but
democrats have to ratchet up the
rhetoric so you get a piece like this
from the new york times today when the
world is on the brink 3.5 trillion
dollars is a pittance a pittance by
abram lustgarten environmental reporter
for propublica wildlife organization
there will be no bargains with an
overheating climate the 3.5 trillion
dollar price tag that president biden
proposed for his climate heavy
build-back battle act might seem
enormous but over the long term it will
be a pittance what we don't spend now
will cost us much more later the bills
for natural disasters and droughts and
power outages are already pouring in
within a few decades the total bill will
be astronomical as energy debts surge
global migration swells industrial
upheaval follows the scale of the threat
demands a new way of thinking about
spending past budgets can no longer
guide how governments spend money in the
future some economists and climate
scientists have calculated climate
change could cost the united states the
equivalent of nearly fourth of nearly
four percent of its gross domestic
product a year by 2100.
four percent is likely a conservative
estimate that comes out to about 840
billion dollars per year four percent of
the american gdp it figured on last
year's economy okay well um
let's say that that's true four percent
of the american gdp that's 840 billion
dollars a year i noticed that you guys
are attempting to spend like a multiple
of that
i noticed that that we are gonna have a
four trillion dollar budget
that we are going to have dumped out 1.9
trillion earlier this year that we spent
seven trillion dollars last year i've
noticed that um
i and and so your notion is we should
spend much more money than it's going to
cost us
again the all of this neglects the fact
that there is going to be future
economic growth and if you crimp the
plan right if you crimp economic growth
with regulation and taxation what you
end up doing is lowering the growth
curve so if you say four percent of
annual gdp you have to estimate how much
the annual gdp is going to be if the
original curve is going to be high and
now you've lowered the curve okay that
curve lowering itself is a major cost
this is something that bjorn lomberg is
constantly pointing out over at the wall
street journal
he says the adaptation doesn't make the
cost of global warming go away entirely
but it does reduce it dramatically
higher temperatures will shrink harvest
if farmers keep growing the same crop
but they're likely to adapt corn
production in north america has shifted
away from the southeast and toward the
upper midwest when sea levels rise
governments build defenses like levees
floodwalls and drainage systems that
protected new orleans for much of
hurricane ida's ferocity this year
nonetheless many in the media push
unrealistic projections of climate
catastrophes while ignoring adaptation
this is correct of course
you can see how far from reality these
sorts of projections are in one heavily
cited study depicted in a graph if you
assume no society will adapt to any sea
level rise between now and 2100 you'll
find that vast areas of the world will
be routinely flooded causing 55 trillion
dollars in damage annually in 2100 or
about 5
of global gdp
but as the study emphasizes in reality
societies are likely to adapt by raising
the height of dikes the study shows
humanity can negate almost all of that
only 15 000 people would be flooded
every year which is a remarkable
improvement compared with the 3.4
million people flooded in 2000
the total cost of damage investments in
new dikes and maintenance costs of
existing dikes will fall six-fold
between now and 2100 to 0.008
of world's gdp so in other words you can
do something about climate change but it
does not require this garbage so what is
this really about what this is really
about is making people dependent on the
government so the white house put
forward another one of these absurd i
mean it's just absurd slide shows now
you remember back in 2012 barack obama
was pushing very hard on spending on
social policy and he put out something
called the life of julia and the life of
julia was roundly mocked because it
showed julia as this woman who was
utterly dependent on government her
entire life and it was openly mocked it
was mocked on late night tv
it was mocked by everybody on the right
most people in the center thought it was
stupid now the biden administration is
bringing it back like i don't know who
there was like life of julia was great
now we need a sequel life of linda so
this is what they did they put together
something called life of linda and i got
to tell you linda leads a pretty sad
life
linda's life according to this is really
pathetic number one
linda is pregnant and there's no father
anywhere in the picture
always always and forever the government
is dead the government is dead this is
the goal right welfare policy it's a
substitute for father
okay so here is the life of linda as
presented by the biden white house right
you're supposed to be optimistic about
this and excited about this this is what
you can hope for from life
linda is a working mother in peoria
illinois she works at a local
manufacturing facility as a production
worker and earns 40 thousand dollars per
year she is pregnant with her son leo
okay so this is i i i love how they have
to just violate all
stop the gender stereotyping she's a
production worker with a hard hat and
she's not a teacher or something right
okay so we'll start with that they're of
course they're women in manufacturing
i'm just saying that heavy manufacturing
is is stereotypically a male industry
and they know that which is why they did
this
once leo is born father nowhere in the
picture by the way linda begins
receiving child tax credits of 300 per
month 3 600 annually to help cover
essential costs like groceries rent
medicine i have a question uh how much
is that going to help if the inflation
outpaces the child tax credit also
if she does not have to work in order to
receive the child tax credit how's that
going to impact the hours that she takes
on at the manufacturing facility is she
just going to stay out of the workforce
considering there are a bevy of other
benefits available to linda
but don't worry the government will step
in regardless
as leo grows up says the white house the
government helps cover the cost for his
daycare guaranteeing that linda doesn't
need to pay more than seven percent of
her income on child care
well that's exciting so we are going to
also make sure that leo can grow up in a
government facility right because again
linda's not married so there are no
options for linda to stay home
with the with the kid
so that's great when leo turns three he
attends a high quality pre-k program for
free
um i have my doubts i have my doubts we
were told that the public schools were
going to be a high quality program for
free
nope
america's public schools are a giant
fail the only public schools that are
good are the ones that are locally
driven by excellent parents
that's that's the big defining factor
pre-k universal pre-k has been a giant
fail
okay the the head start program which
this is modeled on
has poor outcomes
and they're pretty clear about this
being modeled on head start
the head start program according to the
heritage foundation
was launched in 1965 enrolling 560 000
kids in the new federally funded eight
week summer program at the time
proponents were clear that headstart's
sole purpose was to prepare children for
elementary school
unfortunately more than half a century
later it sucks the department of health
and human services which administers
head start revealed in december 2012
2012 that the nearly 8 billion head
start program has little to no impact on
the cognitive social emotional or health
outcomes of participants or the
parenting skills of their parents in
fact participation in head start
actually had some negative effect on
enrolled children
federal researchers reported worse peer
relations and lower teacher assessed
math ability for head start kids
so more cowbell always more cowbell
also
the government accountability office
found several head start centers around
the country actively counseling families
to under-report their incomes in order
to appear eligible for the services so
they were facilitating fraud
among the 175 head start centers
inspected by the inspector general none
fully complied with federal head start
or state requirements to protect
children from unsafe materials and
equipment 21 of 24 grantees did not
fully comply with federal head start or
state requirements to conduct criminal
records checks conduct recurring
background checks document criminal
records checks conduct checks of child
care exclusion list or conduct checks of
child abuse and neglect registries
and we keep spending money on it so
they're like what if we do that okay so
back to the white house plan here so
you've got the little kid going through
the full-scale government program
all the way through
and it doesn't end there there's more
benefits cradle to grave they're not
hiding the ball it's all cradle to grave
stuff from this administration of course
because this is the goal the end goal is
to reorient how americans interact with
the government
this is joe biden's plan is anybody up
for this you wonder why glenn youngkin
is winning in virginia might have
something to do with this okay so back
to leo's story so here's what we know
about leo born to a single mom because
daddy is nowhere in the picture
he's been in government schooling since
he was three
when leo leaves high school he's able to
enroll in communica in a community
college thanks to extended pell grants
and investments in community college so
apparently leo is uh is is not
one of the bright eggs so he goes to the
community college and requires a pell
grant in order to do so and then this is
my favorite part of the whole
presentation thanks to community college
leo lends a good paying union job as a
wind turbine technician
oh will he is that going to be a rich
industry wind turbine technician
honestly god i don't know how many how
many wind turbine technicians are there
how many people work in the wind
industry in the united states
apparently
there are currently 85 000 americans
currently employed in the wind power
industry and related fields
85 000 there are 330 million people but
apparently we're all going to be working
at when at wind farms that's what we're
going to be doing and a union job right
it's going to be a union job
it's going to be an expensive boondoggle
so he's going to be working for the
government effectively because if you're
working on a wind turbine farm there's a
very good shot that that is a government
subsidized job
leo's job is one of four million new
jobs a year supported by president
biden's economic plan right so there it
is so joe biden is going to
quote-unquote create jobs by subsidizing
giveaway goodies to union buddies and
leo's going to work for one of those
people later in life linda needs home
care and hearing care thanks to
president biden's plan linda can access
affordable hearing care through medicare
and leo is able to afford at home at
elder care for his mom
okay so that's again very exciting stuff
so the government is going to pay for
linda to get hearing care because
apparently no elderly people in the
united states have hearing care
that's a new one to me because my
grandmother does actually both
grandmothers do outside of medicare and
um and also
apparently leo was going to leave
mom to rot but now that now that he's
got this subsidy to a union home health
care worker he's going to pay for all
that so again this is this is the ideal
life according to the democrats at no
point is there any upward trajectory or
upward mobility you basically just
stagnate in your lower middle class life
working as
a wind turbine technician on a
government subsidy going to community
college what it what an enriching and
wonderful life that sounds like is that
that great what an enriching wonderful
exciting life for the life of linda
again these are these are very humble
i would say these are pretty humble
aspirations for both leo and linda
they also don't have the slide where
where leo having been brought up in a
government facility all of his life goes
out in the streets and starts burning
down government buildings because he's
very upset that the united states is
systemically racist and unjust
that part they didn't they didn't tell
you about because that part's a little
awkward
but it was right before he went to
community college and also before he got
the wind turbine job
leo gotta love the fictional story see
in in the original american vision the
american dream was
linda works hard she works a job and she
works difficult and long hours but she
also takes care of her kid and she's
married so her husband is around to help
and they together invest enormous time
and effort in their son leo leo goes on
to create a new good product or service
and he then proceeds to start a business
where he hires lots of other people he
becomes inordinately wealthy having made
the country that much better off through
his own innovative skill and risk-taking
right that used to be the american dream
if you were to tell the horatio alger
story of the american dream that was the
american dream and that's true for so
many americans because the fact is the
vast majority of people who start at the
bottom of the american income spectrum
do not end up at the bottom of the
american income spectrum people tend to
rise over the course of their life this
is why older people are richer than
younger people in the united states
but that's not the story the democrats
wish to tell they wish to tell you the
story about a lower income lower middle
income person middle income person who
stays a lower middle income person and
lives their life completely dependent on
government largesse
if that sounds like an inspiring life
story to you
i don't know what to tell you you should
be hoping for more you should be
aspiring for more
it's um
it it it is just amazing to me that this
is
what the biden administration seems to
want to push
that this is the life that they seem to
want you to have
so so wonderful so wonderful meanwhile
as they impoverish you
and as they tell you that we are going
to have to lower our economic estimates
because of climate justice and
environmental justice and white
supremacy and all the rest of the silly
progressive buzzwords
as they tell you that the best you can
hope for is to one day work at a wind
turbine factory with a government
unionized job
as they do that
they are given lottery tickets to
illegal immigrant families that's
exciting stuff according to the wall
street journal
the united states is currently in talks
to pay hundreds of millions of dollars
to families separated at the border
okay again this is kind of incredible
and so so americans are experiencing
wild out of control inflation
they're 10 million open jobs and people
aren't getting back in the workforce we
have supply chain bottlenecks
joe biden is pledging to basically lower
his economic growth estimates to below
two percent a year for the rest of time
but we have enough money in the bank to
be paying i kid you not 450 000
per person in compensation to immigrant
families separated by the trump
administration
there are several agencies working to
resolve lawsuits filed on behalf of
parents and children who say the
government subjected them to lasting
psychological trauma the us departments
of justice homeland security and health
and human services are considering
payments that could amount to close to
one million dollars a family
though the final numbers could shift
people familiar with the matter said
most of the families that cross the
border illegally from mexico to seek
asylum in the united states included one
parent and one child the person said
many families would likely get smaller
payments depending on their
circumstances the aclu has identified
about 5 500 kids separated at the border
over the course of the trump
administration citing figures provided
to it by the government
the number of families eligible under
the potential settlement is expected to
be smaller about 940 claims have so far
been filed by the families the potential
payout could be a billion bucks or more
so remember there is a zero tolerance
enforcement policy in which the united
states would not just release illegal
immigrants into the interior of the
united states after giving them a piece
of paper saying come back in a month
the trump administration said we're not
doing that if you come you will be held
until you actually have your asylum date
until we find out whether you are here
or whether whether you're here for good
reason or whether you're just trying to
cross the border illegally now there was
something called the flora settlement
the florida settlement said that kids
could not be held with their parents in
confinement so instead kids were
separated from parents very often they
were hand handed to a relative sometimes
they'd be put in a holding facility for
a little while right but that was
because of the flora settlement it was
defined by law the two choices were
release the entire family unit into the
interior or two don't and you have to
separate the kids from the parents by
law because of the stupid flora
settlement
so that's what the trump administration
did now if you were one of the illegal
immigrants who came with your kid and
your kid was separated from you the
government is going to sign you a 450
000 check per person
so for your kid and for you
so not only did you get to enter the
united states illegally
you also get a giant check from the u.s
government signed by the taxpayer
is that exciting stuff from the biden
administration
the lawsuits allege some of the children
suffered from a range of ailments
including heat exhaustion and
malnutrition were kept in freezing cold
rooms and provided little medical
attention
that is indeed terrible you know what
else is a really bad idea paying people
for the separation of the family
required by law when they cross the
border you want to incentivize illegal
immigration don't just say come on over
here and we got a bunch of free welfare
benefits and we're not going to kick you
out say if we happen to separate you
because we have to by law we will sign
you a million dollar check
that's crazy towns
in recent months lawyers for the
families and government have told courts
overseeing the cases they are engaged in
settlement negotiations
legal earned deputy director of the aclu
says quote president biden has agreed
that the family separation policy is a
historic moral stain on our nation that
must be fully remedied
that remedy must include not only
meaningful monetary compensation but a
pathway to remain in the country
so again remember that they are not only
pushing for a giant check they're also
pushing for people who just get to stay
here
in his first weeks in office biden
pledged to reunite the separated
families by the way not all the families
have been reunited even still
senator tom cotton said the biden
administration's promises of citizenship
and entitlement programs have already
caused the worst border crisis in
history a huge cash reward will make it
even worse
some government lawyers view the payouts
as excessive for people who had violated
the law by crossing the border
one government lawyer threatened to
remove his name from the case out of
disagreement with the potential
settlement offer
in another instance a department of
homeland security attorney involved in
the settlement talks complained on a
conference call the payouts could amount
to more than some families of 9 11
victims received
so
if that's the case i mean think about
the insane moral logic of that you cross
the border illegally with your kid
because you're attempting to get into
the country illegally
you're separated the government says
here's a million dollar check and you
get to stay in the country
now you're a family member of somebody
who
got vaporized on 911 by a terror attack
on the world trade center you get a
lower check
than the illegal immigrant who just
crossed the border for pain and
suffering
that's unbelievable
trying to take the case's trial would be
unpredictable with juries potentially
awarding larger sums to the family said
legal experts damaged class actions in
this kind of case are pretty rare it's
hard to think of a recent comparison
said margo schlanger who ran the civil
rights office during the obama
administration
it's a complicated complex piece of
litigation to try to resolve hundreds of
different lawsuits at the same time
sometimes even more complex to try the
cases
many of the families file tort claims a
type of civil claim seeking damages for
loss or harm some of the cases were
resolved under the trump administration
in a 2019 settlement in new jersey for
example an adult in a minor received a
total of 125 000
many of those cases were still pending
at the start of the biden administration
but again the fact that this
administration is now considering a
widespread policy of just giving money
to people for this sort of thing like
pretty insane making illegal immigrant
families rich making american families
poor that is a hell of an energy and
making everybody dependent illegal
non-illegal everybody dependent on the
federal government
you wonder why the economic boom is
stalling out
you wonder why a feeling of innervation
has settled across the american
population when it comes to work this
would be the reason
you have an entire side of the political
aisle in the united states that
basically now says that work is
unnecessary you shouldn't aspire to
anything the government will take care
of you cradle to grave if you don't want
to vote for that then vote for glenn
young and if you're in virginia and if
you don't like it don't vote for
democrats across the country in 2022. i
still think that most americans have
aspirations to live more than the life
of linda
if that's the case
then democrats have a real cruising
coming to them the democrats have a real
bruising coming to them in 2022.
alrighty we've reached the end of
today's show however we have another
hour planned for you later plus check
out andrew clavin's show that is every
friday he's got an exciting evening
planned for you as always head on over
to dailywire.com 7 p.m eastern 6 pm
central tune in i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin